l'allemagne n'a pas décrété de
confinement strict comme en france ou en
italie mais toutes les écoles sont
fermées et seuls les commerces de
première nécessité sont ouverts berlin
invite chaque citoyen rester à la maison
quand cela est possible il rassemblement
de plus de deux personnes dans l'espace
public sont interdit au moins jusqu'au
19 avril des mesures de restriction sur
le sol allemand qui commencent à porter
leurs fruits
nous voyons que la propagation du virus
ralenti nous voyons que cela fonctionne
la population doit plus que jamais
observé les restrictions ainsi que les
règles d'hygiène et de distanciation
social de rigueur l'allemagne a commencé
très tôt à faire tester ses habitants
une politique massive de dépistage mis
en place dès le premier cas avéré en
bavière fin janvier près de cinq cent
mille personnes sont testés au kovy 19
dans le pays chaque semaine berlin
pourrait même rapidement monté à 200
mille tests par jour d'après un document
du ministère de l'intérieur une
stratégie choisie notamment par la corée
du sud qui est prise pour exemple
aujourd'hui par plusieurs pays
et si l'allemagne était cir est active
dans sa politique de dépistage et bien
c'est aussi parce que le premier test au
mondial de détection de couronnes un
virus a été découvert par une équipe de
chercheurs allemands
autre stratégie inspirée par
l'expérience sud coréennes ou encore
singapourienne l'utilisation des
téléphones portables et du bluetooth
pour endiguer la pandémie
une application est actuellement testée
avec l'aide de l'armée allemande
si une personne est infectée
l'application verra un push à tous ceux
qu'elle aura croisé dans les deux
semaines précédentes
pour les avertir d'un risque de
contamination cela fonctionne d'une
manière absolument pas en forme à la
protection des données
cela signifie que les lieux les
personnages se croisent ne seront pas
adoptés ni l'identité des utilisateurs
mais aussi ce train est l'idée
d'utiliser les données téléphoniques
semblent de plus en plus faire son
chemin dans l'opinion publique
un allemand sur deux y seraient
favorables d'après les derniers sondages
comme c'est un diplôme que va suivre qui
utilise exactement 1 mais seulement
quelle personne a été en contact
et l'autre dont les encres ou alors je
me sens très bien que l'on ait alerté
les gens de manière anonyme
la chancellière allemande connaît de son
côté un regain de popularité auprès de
la population satisfaite de sa bonne
gestion de la crise sanitaire
angela merkel qui a repris le chemin de
la chancellerie ce vendredi elle a
effectué trois tests de détection du
colis 19 tous se sont avérés négatifs